afternoon my name is Paul Clary I'm the
Dean of the Yale School of Public Health
and I'm absolutely delighted to welcome
all of you to this third confirming of
the Centennial award of the CEA Winslow
medal by the Yale School of Public
Health on dr. Judith rodent on behalf of
the school I'd like to extend our
immense gratitude to the faculty staff
students and alumni representatives that
comprise both the Winslow medal
selection committee and the centennial
planning committee both chaired by our
deputy Dean dr. Brian Lederer for making
this historic occasion possible the
Winslow medal is given an honor the
founder of our school and many say
founder of modern public health in the
United States it's awarded to world
renowned innovators with distinguished
careers and outstanding achievements in
public health leadership scholarship and
contributions to society past recipients
include Sir Richard Dahl bill [ __ ] Sir
Ian Chalmers and in this centennial year
Sir Michael Marmot and dr. Anthony 5g
nominations for the Centennial medal
were sought from the entire Yale School
of Public Health community from the
deans of schools of public health
throughout the country as well as from
key leaders at the National Institutes
of Health the Centers for Disease
Control and the World Health
Organization before introducing dr.
Rodin permit me to say a few words about
CEA Winslow he was born in 1877 and
after being educated at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology he
taught at the University of Chicago the
City College of New York Columbia and
Yale and served as editor of the Journal
of bacteriology in the American Journal
of Public Health and was president of
the American Public Health Association
Yale Winslow was chairman of the
University's Department of Public Health
at its inception in 1915 and the course
of his 30-year tenure he brought Yale
the department and himself considerable
international and
distinction and acclaim obviously a lot
has changed in the last century and a
lot has changed in the area of public
health during that time hygiene
developed into preventive medicine
bacteriology evolved to include
parasitology and virology classical
epidemia d me ology involved to include
clinical epidemiology control of
communicable diseases became chronic
disease control and public health
increasingly focused on the social
determinants of illness and health
Winslow developed public health into a
premier educational program that
graduated not only students with masters
and doctoral degrees in public health
but also medical and students imbued
with quote unquote a preventive spirit
yeah it was the first academic
institution in the u.s. to recognize the
importance of public health by
establishing a degree granting program
in the field in 1946 the program was one
of the first small groups of schools to
be nationally accredited as a School of
Public Health 100 years after the
inception of our school and with the
communities across the planet facing
both old and new formidable health
challenges it is fitting to award the
CEA Winslow medal to dr. rodent
recognized by Forbes magazine as one of
the world's 100 most powerful women in
three consecutive years as everyone here
knows dr. Rodin is the president of the
Rockefeller Foundation one of the
world's leading philanthropic
organizations her journey to this post
is marked by her lifelong dedication to
the health and well-being of populations
around the globe dr. Rodin was trained
as a research psychologist and when as
the pioneers of behavioral medicine and
health psychology in fact the first time
I met dr. Rodin I was a graduate student
and dr. Rodin very early in her career
but clearly one of the rising stars in
the world was invited in as one of the
noteworthy speakers of psychologists
around the country after completing her
PhD at Columbia University she joined
the
50 of NYU and was an assistant professor
psychology she then moved to Yale in
1972 launching a 22-year career here at
Yale dr. rodent earned an international
reputation as both the pioneer the
women's health movement and one of the
early psychologists to study both the
biological and psychological factors
that led to obesity from 1983 to 1989 t3
she chaired an international research
network studying health promoting and
health damaging behavior for the
MacArthur Foundation prior to
appointment as Yale's Provost in 1992
she served two years as chair of the
department of psychology and one year as
the Dean of the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences a pioneer and innovator
throughout her career
dr. Roden was the first woman named to
lead an Ivy League university when she
was named president of the University of
Pennsylvania in 1994 and the first woman
to serve the Rockefeller found as the
Rockefeller Foundation's president dr.
Rowan has received 19 honorary Doctorate
degrees and is the author of more than
250 academic articles and has written or
co-written 15 books including her two
most recent the power of impact
investing and the resilience dividend
being strong in a world where things go
wrong and if you have not read those
books I recommend an extremely high uuk
to you you will benefit from reading
them and be better for it a widely
recognized international leader in
academia science and development issues
dr. Rodin has actively participated in
influential global forums including the
World Economic Forum Council and former
relations Clinton Global Institute and
the United Nations General Assembly dr.
Rodin is also a member of the African
Development Bank's high-level panel and
a board member of the Alliance for a
green revolution in Africa which was
co-founded by the Rockefeller Foundation
since joining the Rockefeller Foundation
a decade ago dr. Roden has transformed
the foundations focused for the 21st
century
launching major initiatives around the
world
to bolster resilience to climate change
in poor communities strength and global
healthcare systems
catalyze the field of impact investing
mobilize an agricultural revolution in
Africa and shape smarter more
sustainable transplant transportation
policies in the United States the
foundation system based approach is
enabling innovative solutions to the
world's most pressing problems plus a
secure food water housing and
infrastructure global health environment
and climate change urbanization and
social and economic security in some
there are few people in the world who
have had a such a profound impact on
global public health and resilience and
the spirit of Winslow this work has
involved innovative interdisciplinary
solutions that directly promote
Winslow's goal of preventing disease and
promoting health
it is us an extraordinary honor and
privilege for me to present the
Centennial CEA Winslow medal to our
esteemed guests please welcome dr.
Judith Rodin to share a vision for the
future of public health public health
2.0 aligning people and the planet
well this is wonderful thank you so much
Dean Cleary and I understand that you'll
be stepping down in the spring so let me
take a moment to congratulate you on
your success in leading this vital
institution into its second century I
can't tell you how delighted I am to be
back in New Haven so thank you for
giving me the opportunity to come home
looking out across this audience of
scholars and students women and men from
literally all over the world
I marvel remembering my early days here
when L was hardly as diverse in fact
when I first came for my lunch interview
and I think Allen Wagner will remember
this for my faculty position I had to go
in the side door at Morrie's which was
the only way that women could enter that
then all-male Club it now seems so long
ago and yet we still have so much
further to go to ensure that the
incredible gains we've made in public
health and in so many other areas are
felt equally by women and girls around
the world but that's a topic for another
lecture I spent more than two decades
here as you heard the bulk of my
academic career in these halls and labs
and offices from Kirtland Hall to York
and Whitney Street Yale is where I grew
as a scholar and as an investigator
where I gained inspiration from
brilliant students as a teacher and
where I had the privilege of challenging
and mentoring some of the world's most
foremost thinkers really indoors
including my postdoc and your colleague
and recipient of the Connecticut Public
Health Association's Winslow award
genetic Avex
and my dissertation advisory your
president
Peters aliv a Yale gave me the
opportunity and the space to do work
that pushed the boundaries of the
disciplines of Public Health and
psychology and medicine at a time when
this was extremely uncommon and very
very difficult to do elsewhere it is
also where I learned my first lessons in
the science and the art mostly the art
of leading large institutions for
instance how as Provost to balance
interest to keep more than a dozen
diverse and strong-willed entities the
college the Graduate School the
extraordinary professional schools
including the School of Public Health
working together and pulling in the same
direction I will always feel incredibly
lucky and grateful for my years at Yale
so thank you for honoring me and for
inviting me to be part of the School of
Public Health centennial celebrations it
is humbling to be included in this
remarkable list of public health heroes
that the Dean mentioned including the
myko recipients Tony Fauci and Michael
Marmot and so many of the public health
as I think about it gains made in the
last century the creation of
Connecticut's Department of Public
Health the idea of prevention as a
cornerstone of public health the idea of
how to improve air quality in schools
building low-income housing
strengthening nursing education can be
traced at least in part to Winslow's
leadership his energy and his vision so
I am truly honored to receive the medal
that bears his name today as we
celebrate the great achievements made by
the school of public health in the last
hundred years I'd like to spend our time
together to highlight the urgent and
complex health challenges waiting for us
in the next hundred and how we can meet
them by supporting the creation of a new
discipline a discipline that we are
currently calling planetary health the
Rockefeller commitment to public health
began
19:09 a few years before the foundation
was officially chartered with a million
dollar investment by john d rockefeller
senior to launch the first ever public
health campaign in american history at
the time four out of every ten people in
the American South were infected with
hookworm the majority of its victims
were poor they lived in dilapidated
housing with primitive or no plumbing
the disease sapped victims energy
leaving them unable to learn or to work
trapping them their families and their
communities in poverty while hookworm
was devastating and pervasive scientific
advances had made the disease treatable
and Rockefellers great insight which led
in part to the creation of the field of
Public Health was that it was
preventable through improvements in
sanitation such as the construction of
latrines and widespread education about
the disease however the South's capacity
to bring this knowledge to bear was
extremely limited at the time just three
southern states supported a Health
Department the rockefeller sanitary
commission for the eradication of
hookworm disease recognize that if
efforts were to be successful battling
the disease would have to be
interdisciplinary community-wide
involving both treatment and prevention
one that depended not just on the hard
work of doctors and nurses but also on
the mobilisation of government officials
churches schools the press and other
actors all working together they
enlisted communities in a three pronged
approach first mapping the disease
second diagnosing and treating patients
and third and perhaps most important
educating the public about sanitation
and prevention the approach worked and
eventually families were able to live
free of this health threat most
importantly the campaign led to the
establishment of public health bureaus
and systems in states and counties that
didn't have them
success of the hookworm campaign
convinced Rockefeller and his advisors
of the power of a public health approach
to reach and improve the health of
entire communities not just individuals
with access to medical care they
recognized that by investing in public
health as its own field they could
create an entirely new discipline one
that would foster new ways of thinking
forge new solutions and train a new
cadre of health professionals I am proud
to note that Professor Winslow and Yale
were important early pioneers and
partners of the Foundation's public
health work in 1918 when the foundation
sought to explore ways to increase the
corps of public health nurses we found a
strong ally and professor Winslow and
appointed him chair of our committee for
the study of public health nursing
education this led to the creation the
creation of the Rockefellers supported
Yale School of Nursing in 1923 the first
University based School of Nursing in
America we supported Yale's early
efforts to bring together the teaching
of public health and preventive medicine
and in 1964 we transferred the
Rockefeller Foundation virus laboratory
to the Yale School of Public Health
bringing-- leading Rockefeller funded
scientists to Yale including dr. max
Thaler a Nobel Prize winner for his work
on yellow fever certainly there's no
question that due to the agricultural
industrial and public health innovations
of the 20th century we in the 21st
century are living healthier more
prosperous and more productive lives
than ever life expectancy has doubled as
you can see in this slide infant and
maternal mortality are declining
throughout the world and 8 out of every
10 people are living in countries now
where poverty is decreasing in fact just
last month the World Bank and
that by the end of this year for the
first time in history fewer than one in
ten of the world's people will be living
in extreme poverty and that is a
remarkable advance the tremendous
economic progress that has accompanied
these health advances are notable
however they have required very
substantial alteration of our natural
systems about a third of the ice-free
and desert free land service a surface
has been converted to cropland or
pasture and every year roughly half of
all accessible freshwater is
appropriated for human use since 2000
human beings have cut down more than 2.3
million square kilometres of primary
forests with the new areas of
deforestation shown on the red in this
map we've dammed more than 60 percent of
the world's rivers the environmental
cost of all this activity and progress
has been quite substantial from
shrinking rainforests to declining
biodiversity from severe water shortages
to the acidification of oceans from
unchecked air pollution to rising
temperatures around the world for
example an example well known I'm sure
to many in this audience the
concentration of major greenhouse gases
carbon dioxide methane nitrous oxide
have reached their highest levels for at
least the past 800,000 years with the
most dramatic increase as you can see in
the figure on the right in the last 60
years
in addition today species are going
extinct at a rate more than a hundred
times that observed in fossil records
and vertebrate species have had their
population sizes cut in half in only the
past forty five years while the
degradation of biodiversity and the
environment
has been recognized and certainly many
of you are working in this area it's
extreme impact on human health may not
be as widely recognized I can say it
simply we have been mortgaging the
health of future generations to realize
economic and development gains in the
present by unsustainably exploiting
nature's resources it is very clear that
up till now human civilization has
flourished but now with substantial
health effects on future generations
from the degradation of nature's
life-support systems all of nature's
life-support systems not only those
affected by climate change these
striking trends are exacerbated by
highly an equitable inefficient and
unsustainable patterns of resource
consumption and technological
development together of course with
population growth for example the same
fossil fuels driving development have
also led to high levels of air pollution
especially in our fastest-growing cities
as many of you well know particulate
matter caused by the combustion of
fossil fuels specifically fine
particulate matter with the diameter of
10 microns or less can penetrate and
lodge deep in the lungs contributing to
the development of cardiovascular
diseases as well as lung cancer
respiratory diseases as well the World
Health Organization has found that 7
million men women and children die
prematurely every year due to these air
pollution related diseases nearly 9 of
10 of these early deaths occur among
people living in low and middle income
countries as noted in the next slide
which is a breakdown of those deaths
attributed to specific diseases linked
to air pollution on the left outdoor air
pollution and on the right indoor air
pollution most of the deaths are
attributable to cardiovascular disease
and stroke but and here
is a critical point that is not widely
understood if you add together all of
the disease outcomes and focus only on
outdoor air pollution more people die
from outdoor air pollution alone than
from malaria and hiv/aids combined but
look at the distribution of our research
funding scientists predict that if an
action is taken the number of deaths if
no action is taken I'm sorry the number
of deaths caused by outdoor air
pollution will double by the year 2050
next everyday we're seeing the impact of
environmental changes on health outcomes
related to food security soil erosion
and desertification have taken some 12
million hectares of agricultural land
offline and you can see that noted in
the yellow and orange on this slide so
we are at an increasingly rapid rate
clearing land and in many cases
destroying land for agricultural
production but we are doing it so
inefficiently and ineffectively that the
data show that it's resulting in a loss
of up to 20 million tons of grain every
year in just one generation 37 African
countries have experienced reduced
agricultural output due to a dramatic
decline in soil fertility
in addition declining numbers of animal
pollinators such as honeybees threatens
both agricultural productivity and
nutrition over 25 percent of the world's
most important crops depend on animal
pollinators crop pollination by insects
has been estimated to be worth fourteen
point six billion dollars a year to the
US economy alone moreover many plant
derived sources of vitamin A iron and
foliate folate depend on pollination a
decline in these crops leads to vitamin
deficiencies under nutrition and even
increased death rates reducing carbon
dioxide levels recognized as a key
driver of climate change are another
effective intervention but instead as we
see we see rising levels of carbon
dioxide if that continues they are also
expected to reduce the amount of key
nutrients in staple grains such as wheat
and rice so the indirect effects on
human health are demonstrated here
without a reversal of these levels the
impact on poor communities who are
especially dependent on these grains for
nutrition could truly be catastrophic
in addition our fisheries around the
world are in dramatic decline nearly 90%
of global Marine Fisheries are
overexploited or fully exploited
according to FAO Ellis essman Marine
Fisheries supplied the main animal
protein for more than a billion people
and nearly 3 billion people get 20% or
more of their animal protein from fish
today in a stunning statistic that
really is not well known Europe seas are
estimated to hold less than 5 percent of
the total mass of fish that once swam in
those waters we often think that is
Japan that is overfishing but European
fishermen are now fishing deeply off the
coast of Africa because of the decline
in fish in their own waters further
global environmental degradation has
changed patterns of some of the
emergence and spread of disease for
example recent estimates suggests that
an additional 200 million people are at
risk of malaria due to climate change
rising temperatures this is a right a
rise of 0.85 degrees Celsius since 1880
with a projected rise as we know between
two point six and four point eight
degrees by the end of the
21st century are causing diseases that
were once limited to the tropics shown
in yellow and they're moving further to
Europe and North America which you can
see shown in red the risk of new
patterns of malaria transmission is also
increasing of course as deforestation
creates new breeding sites in which
malaria carrying mosquitoes thrive
importantly they don't exist in such
abundance in an intact rainforest
it is human disturbances that creates
their optimal habitat further a quarter
of all natural habitats have been
converted to other land uses leading to
increasing human contact with wildlife
an increased risk of transmission of
potentially deadly animal borne diseases
such as Ebola which we saw so tragically
in West Africa environmentally linked
declines and biodiversity have also
eliminated predators who kept disease
carrying vectors in check these are just
a few of literally hundreds of examples
of the connection between the health of
our planet and our own health just two
years ago the Rockefeller Foundation
celebrated our own centennial and to
help mark that milestone we had has held
a series of probing forward-looking
conferences around the world during our
meeting in Beijing we challenged the
participants to dream the future of
public health for the next hundred years
the health and environmental challenges
I just described so briefly we're very
much on the minds of everyone there as
we looked out on and breathed in the
smog in that city
we reached consensus that we needed a
new frame for public health in the 21st
century one that builds on the
innovations of the 20th century but also
recognizes the inextricable link between
human health and the natural systems the
full array of natural system
on which life depends one that ensures
that the activity of human systems be
they political economic or social
aligned with the requirements of natural
systems to ensure that we have safe
sustainable environments which are
essential to human health and prosperity
in other words we need an approach that
embraces not just public health but
planetary health a public health 2.0 if
you will how my public health 2.0 differ
from its previous version we all know
that more than a hundred and fifty years
ago Jon Snow
perhaps truly the father of modern
epidemiology was able to trace the
source of a deadly cholera epidemic to a
single contaminated water pump in London
you can see from the map on the slide
how the epidemiological approach
identified so clearly the source of
contamination however in the 21st
century the root cause of planetary
health challenges are not always as
specific as a single contaminated water
pump the solution not always as easy as
the simple removal of its handle let's
take the example of schistosomiasis the
snail born parasitic disease affecting
millions in tropical and subtropical
nations and you can see especially so in
Africa studies have shown that
schistosomiasis infections rise in
communities that are nearby dams being
built the standing water created by dam
reservoirs enable infected snails to
thrive and to reproduce in greater
numbers we know that the public health
methodology of mapping and education and
treatment has made tremendous
differences in combating the disease but
a planetary health approach where public
health professionals would be
consistently working at
the beginning of the process with
engineers with government planners with
environmental scientists to make
well-informed dynamic decisions about
where and how development occurs might
prevent outbreaks from occurring in the
first place
and yield more lasting results that is
the potential of planetary health I
congratulate you on your new program on
climate change and health and I had a
chance to chat with some of its faculty
leaders this morning and it embraces
many of the planetary health principles
already I hope as we discussed this
morning that we can work together on
this issue in the years to come
progressing beyond climate change to
think about the impacts of all of our
natural systems on health launching a
new field as we know from experience
requires a lot of changes huge changes
in public policy the creation of
government agencies transformations in
research and training and the ch-- and
the really changing of public
expectations and behavior making people
think and behave in new ways it also
requires the melding of disciplines in
new ways bringing together diverse minds
and opportunities to problem solving
public health practitioners and
environmental scientists as you are
doing but also veterinarians forestry
experts economists engineers
technologists systems thinkers and urban
planners following our January 2013
Beijing meeting the foundation convened
in partnership with the british medical
journal the lancet a moti disciplinary
group to develop a set of principles to
guide this proposed new field of
planetary health based on their
recommendations we're funding some
preliminary activities we're supporting
research efforts such as the Wildlife
Conservation Society's heal initiative
which is a consortium of 20 partners
working to
to explore rigorously the linkages
between human health and natural systems
we're also funding the creation of a
planetary health alliance and steering
committee to develop curricula to train
the world's first planetary health
scientists convene and work with
scholars around the world and conduct
advocacy work to ensure an enabling
policy environment for planetary health
to help test our new concept
we're also piloting planetary health
solutions for diverse and pressing
challenges ranging from fighting Ebola
to fighting forest fires let me give you
an example so you can see how
far-reaching this can be taken there's
no question if you think if you look at
the data on the growth of intensity and
impact of forest fires this is in the
western United States that these have
been hugely on the rise and that they
are caused by in part by human activity
we also know that such fires pose a
great threat to human health both
directly through toxins released into
the air and indirectly through the loss
of biodiversity essential to buffering
disease but the burden of fighting so
many forest fires with limited resources
has kept the u.s. Forest Service from
focusing on fire prevention even though
the data show that it is 40 times more
costly to try to fight and suppress
wildfires after the fact than it is to
prevent them so we have funded the
development of forest resilience impact
bonds to be sold in the open market for
the first time this year which will
raise badly needed funds from private
investors to finance forest restoration
treatments to reduce the intensity and
frequency of wild fires and also through
these interventions to increase water
availability and water purity for local
communities
investors are paid back by local water
and electric companies through their
Rizzo
cost savings from the intervention the
Forest Service wins they benefit from
cost-effective preventive measures while
investors win because they reap both
financial and environmental returns for
catalyzing a social good so what this
planetary health approach allows you to
do among other things is figure out how
to align incentives among all of the
actors so that you can have
transformational impact in launching
this new field of planetary health I
think we will face three big challenges
the first is one of imagination for the
last 85 years the world has relied on
gross domestic product as the chief
indicator of human progress but we have
failed to account for future health and
environmental harms over present day
gains with the disproportionate effects
of those harms on the poor and those in
developing nations we must imagine and
establish a new indicator one that
measures human progress as what measures
our progress as progress in balancing
economic development with human health
and protecting the environment as two
critical components in that metric the
second challenge is a research and
information challenge there are still so
many significant gaps in our
understanding of the social and
environmental drivers of human health as
well as of course the impacts of natural
systems and climate we've got to
increase our support for inter and
transdisciplinary research necessary to
bridge these gaps and here I know I'm
preaching to the choir but present
research limitations should not delay
action which brings me to the final
challenge a governance challenge we've
got to find ways to help and encourage
governments and institutions to respond
much more quickly and much more nimbly
to environmental and health threats as
there
and to embed directly into the DNA of
government policy making a proactive
recognition of and a respect for the
links between economic development
natural systems and human health the
appreciation of nature's capital and
nature's subsidy should be accounted for
so that economy and nature are not
falsely separated if we continue to fall
asleep them we will continue to threaten
the health of the future policies should
balance social progress environmental
sustainability and the economy and those
working on it need to systematically
think about all three simultaneously to
support a world population of nine
billion or more which is the produc
projec prediction resilient food and
agricultural systems are needed to
address both under nutrition and over
nutrition to reduce waste diversify
diets and minimize environmental damage
planetary health we believe offers an
unprecedented opportunity for advocacy
of global and national reforms new types
of taxes and subsidies for many sectors
of the economy including energy
agriculture water fisheries and health
and regional economic trade treaties
such as those we are working very hard
to sign now should act to further
incorporate the protection of natural
systems and health in the near and
long-term and not be separated out as
they have been in the past I invite all
of you to join in this mission to seize
unparalleled opportunities to seek new
knowledge to harness new technologies
and to create new forms of governance to
advance planetary health it is clear
that the challenges before us are
serious in some cases I would say even
dire but we can't afford to just shrug
and hope for the best
as a psychologist I'm committed to the
belief that individual and collective
involvement in the world is worthwhile
we can never underestimate the human
capacity to damage but also our capacity
to remedy to mitigate and to build anew
if anything that is what the last
hundred years or more of our respective
institutions and this great field of
Public Health have taught us and it's
what will inspire us to launch a new
approach to health for the next century
enabling as CEA Winslow had hoped and I
quote for every citizen to realize his
or her birthright of health and
longevity thank you
Wow
thank you for that daunting but
inspiring vision of the future and the
challenges that face us and I'd like to
welcome dr. genetic Avex one of our
steam faculty members for some brief
comments and then there'll be a question
and answer period Judy it's a profound
honor to be here with you today to
celebrate your CEA Winslow medal in this
our centennial year as you know I've
just returned from London and I did go
actually to C I went to Soho to see the
pump but I was also reminded I couldn't
resist you know but I was also reminded
of the formative work of Sir Geoffrey
Rose in the strategy of preventive
medicine published nearly a quarter of a
century ago and as many of my colleagues
and students know Sir Geoffrey Rose
famously set forth the theorem that a
large number of people exposed to a
small risk may generate many more cases
of disease than a small number of people
exposed to a large risk your career is
marked in part by a corollary to this
theorem specifically that a large number
of people exposed to an intervention
with even modest effects may generate
the most productive health gains and it
seems to me that this is part of your
vision and so I bring this forward today
reflecting on your career at Yale and at
Penn and now as president of the
Rockefeller Foundation which indeed is
focused on the importance of
evidence-based and evidence-informed
interventions to catalyze change your
early work and aging and obesity and in
women's health and your work now on
planetary health has stretched the
boundaries of traditional thinking as we
have all heard today and as such you
have and will continue to
have impact on millions of lives both
domestically and globally you are a
visionary and you've been able to bring
this vision to reality because you
inspire others because you conduct and
support the most rigorous science and
because you imbue a sense of passion
compassion and dedication to your work
and to those of us who've been
privileged to be around you so I had the
opportunity to work with Judy beginning
in 1989 and I felt like you took a big
risk hiring me as a new postdoc with
limited experience but I had an
insatiable appetite to observe and to
learn from you and the incredible
transdisciplinary team that you
assembled at Kirtland Hall and also as
part of the McArthur network on health
and behavior you fostered in me and in
others the grit and determination to
bring evidence to action to improve the
health and well-being of individuals and
of communities and particularly of those
underserved and vulnerable Judy you gave
me the opportunity to come to this great
institution of Yale to learn and in turn
to teach and mentor the next generation
of scholars in psychology and forestry
in medicine and in public health in your
talk today you reminded us of the deep
foundation of a century of public health
upon which we build from the eradication
of hookworm to unprecedented social and
economic progress nonetheless you
articulated the grave threats of climate
change and environmental degradation and
persistent poverty you stated the
connection between the health of our
planet and our own is abundantly clear
and you set forth three challenges to us
all to foster imagination to generate
knowledge
and to develop and implement governance
structures to improve public and
planetary health these are tremendous
challenges though ones as part of the
academic lineage of CEA Winslow to which
we should feel determined to rise how
can we align incentives for
transformational impact as you posed and
with that I get to congratulate you once
again as the recipient of the CA Winslow
medal I thank you for ceding my career
and so many others and I turn it open to
you for questions and comments and as
you get your thoughts together I will
take the chairs prerogative of the very
first question and ask how do we best
foster imagination within academia and
between academia and the many other
stakeholders I really do think we talked
so much about systems thinking and I
think it starts there but I'm really
talking about systems action we need
deep disciplinary research that is the
fundamental building block for all of
this but if we don't design and
understand the total system and each of
us is working on one small piece we miss
the huge opportunity to imagine where
the tipping points are so we talk all
the time at Rockefeller about leverage
and whenever we go into an area or try
to create a new area we actually mapped
the whole system and we do that because
we want to seed those things that look
like they had the opportunity to produce
tipping points and that's one part of
imagination we want to diagnose
immediately where what we call the
antibodies in the system are going to be
those elements that are going to push
against the interventions that we're
trying and often we don't do
that enough in our work we we have a
amazing vision and great hypotheses and
we're testing and challenging but we
don't ask ourselves what other forces in
that system may be pushing against our
very good ideas and our very good
interventions so that part of
imagination is critical and then I think
we cannot confront the challenges of the
21st century certainly these challenges
without finding unlikely partners new
ways of influencing and interacting with
governments deep and important new ways
of engaging the private sector there's
so much of what we do and what we fund
at Rockefeller and I mentioned this just
in the in the forest forest resilience
pond examples but you can really be
transformational if you figure out how
to align incentives but often so much of
what we're trying to accomplish
conflicts with incentives that another
element of that system has and we don't
think about it enough we don't imagine
how we could realign things to align
incentives and I talked about a couple
of interesting examples with some of
your colleagues this morning and so as
we do that you really can have
transformational impact I'll give you
one quick example and then throw it open
to others for questions I shared with
them an experience that sabmiller had
the bottling not only bottling beer
producing company and the largest
bottling plant in Bolivia was their
plant and they found no in Colombia
forgive me
they found that their water costs were
increasing dramatically and they were
ready to pull out of Bogota and other
parts of the country and we brought them
together with the Nature Conservancy
because obviously something there's some
reason why the cost of water is going up
and so the Nature Conservancy examined
what was going on upstream and they
found that dairy farmers because of
climate change were clearing more and
more
for their herds to graze and that was
degrading the riverbanks and the soil
was falling into the river and so the
cost of cleaning the water was
escalating dramatically instead of
leaving they looked at what their costs
of water were then and what they had
been and they collaborated and they
bought new kinds of herds for the
upstream farmers herds that were more
productive and required less grazing
land so and then the Nature Conservancy
taught the farmers how to also be
riverbed stewards they didn't know what
they were doing and they didn't
understand the impact of their behavior
so the quest of water went back down the
the dairy herds became more productive
therefore increasing the livelihoods of
the dairy farmers and the environment
was better secured and better restored
that's what I mean by saying you can
look at every point in the system and
intervene if you think about it
differently those interventions are
possible this is the kind of thing that
ultimately I think is is necessary when
we talk about imagination really really
needing to change there are Heidi's
coming with afternoon my name is Raphael
Paris's camellia I'm a professor with
chronic disease epidemiology and social
and behavioral sciences and thank you
very very much for a most inspiring a
presentation I was a member of the 2015
Dietary Guidelines Advisory Committee
and for the first time we included the
topic of sustainability with a strong
message that food choices matter for the
health of the planet and the hope was
that the federal government would end up
incorporating that aspect of our report
into the Dietary Guidelines for
Americans policy document however as you
imagine that beef industry got extremely
upset we were decision to include that
aspect in our report lobbied very
strongly with Congress and Congress
called for hearings specifically the
house agricultural committee were they
tried the secretaries of health and
agriculture essentially forbidding them
from including the topic of
sustainability as part of the Dietary
Guidelines for Americans so my question
is how can we what can we do to navigate
better these waters and end all
policymakers and food industry to behave
in a different way to protect the health
of the planet so I didn't say this was
easy I just said it's necessary I do
think we are seeing glimmers where we
can push against a more open door and my
advice would be to start there again we
work on reports with specific a specific
focus and if that specific focus doesn't
get adopted it's it's easy to
immediately imagine that nothing will or
can because there's opposition so the
Department of Agriculture just announced
a huge commitment to reducing waste and
spoilage in the food chain by the year
2050 we helped with the mayor of Milan
launched a initiative that hundreds of
cities around the world have signed on
to and gave a declaration to the
Secretary General in October to reduce
waste and spoilage in their cities so if
we conquered the waist and spoilage
continuum from post-harvest loss all the
way to what winds up in the garbage can
in the developed and developing world we
could feed 9 billion people nutritiously
in the future it is the single largest
intervention that is necessary but it
takes imagination across every element
of the value chain so new technologies
for
holder farmers hermetic bags on-farm
processing so that they get less
post-harvest loss developing new kinds
of secondary markets so that things get
to market more easily takes a different
kind of intervention and then as we are
doing in addition to that negotiating
with multinational sorcerer's big
companies to buy the aggregation of what
these small holders are doing so that's
the sort of developing world post
harvests to table and then the developed
world as we all know is paying much more
attention now to sustainability large
companies in how they're sourcing
companies that use a lot of fish
sustainable fishing so you start to see
where those elements are changeable I
think that's one I think a second is how
many large companies have committed to
zero impact on water so a lot of the
large bottlers now a lot of the large
chemical companies really understanding
that unbelievable effect that loss of
fresh water is having and the
degradation of the water supply on the
future of the planet have really
committed themselves twenty years ago
they would have lobbied against this
there's absolutely no question so start
working if you really are serious about
this not just in the thing that you are
most passionate about but the thing that
you think can show the most
demonstration of how it works because
that's ultimately what will move in
other industries and government policies
and the like
I was asked and did work with Fortune
magazine this year to help them create a
list of the 20 companies in the world
who have shown most effectively that
they can make a profit and do well for
the environment and and having social
impact it's in the september fortune and
it's worth taking a look at
because you want to you you can name in
shame or you can celebrate those
activities where it is going on as
another way to keep pushing the kind of
progress that we need and that you can
talked about dr. Amy justice measurement
people and I know you are as well
it strikes me that the measurements that
we use that to have driven public health
to where we are now probably need to be
rethought and I'm curious what you think
the metrics of the future should be to
drive planetary health so we've been
funding an initiative that started with
Michael Porter called the social
Progress Index which is really trying to
replace the economic price index and
many many countries voluntarily in the
testing phase allowed themselves to be
pilot countries and it measures both
individual health and well-being
economic variables and social variables
but also natural systems in the health
of the planet that's that's one there's
one that I'm less familiar with but it's
getting a lot of attention called the
Happy Planet Index so that's another
where so clearly you're right that what
we measure what we can measure we pay
attention to when we transform that
which we measure it starts to be really
critical in helping to affect the
systems change that we're really looking
for and I do think that as all of these
kinds of experiments with alternative
metrics arise we need your colleagues
don't leave out the economists in all
this stuff that you're doing they really
really are critical partners to produce
this kind of change because it really is
among everything economic progress that
has really helped to produce this Venn
decline and this rapid decline that
we're seeing and again I want to
re-emphasize so much that this is way
more than climate change this is a total
loss of biodiversity on which everything
in the environment and then everything
in human health depend and so we've got
to get back down to the root causes and
many of these variables as we start to
approach this problem we break for lunch
we'll take one more go across the street
for lunch and the economist dr. Jody
Sindelar had her hand up earlier he
seemed to queue her up great professor
here in the School of Public Health and
health policy and management and I
someone answered my question but I
appreciate that you expanded the view of
what is public health to planetary
health but I was wondering if one of the
key segments or points of your analysis
should be emphasizing social issues more
not just social as we all know and I
know you know well social determinants
of health but also social outcomes and
maybe you answered that a little bit
when you talked about different ways of
measuring well-being so just that's my
basically right so absolutely the way
this is being formulated social
variables are both independent variables
and dependent variables in this process
so we know and of course Michael Marmot
spoke to this group about the social
determinants of health but social
outcomes are determined by these natural
systems and by what we are doing in
terms of natural systems so who is hurt
more for example we we at Rockefeller do
an enormous amount of work on resilience
as I think you know and if you look at
who's most affected by the shocks and
stresses that are coming with increasing
frequency whether they're tsunamis and
typhoons or hurricanes or it's always
the poor and most vulnerable both
because of where they live
and because of their capacity to their
limit more limited capacity to rebound
more effectively so what's great about
taking a systems approach here is that
you're not limited to a view of just
antecedents and outcomes as one or
another of these types of variables it
really is quite quite circular and you
need to think about it that way which is
a new methodology I think in terms of
our statistical tools as well as a new
framework for how you're you're really
developing your hypotheses and and what
you're testing so I I have the great
privilege of being able to really have
worked in Fundamental Research have
worked in Applied Research and now as a
funder and one that really is able to
look you know in a very systemic way to
try to tip systems as as we talked about
it to step back and take a wider lens to
really thinking about some of these
issues and I have found it so profoundly
important and so incredibly useful in
breaking down kind of narratives in
finding new allies and in generating new
ways of thinking so I've been very
privileged and I'm happy to share a bit
of that with you today thank you